what's the best moment you've had as an
actor the best moment I've had as an
actor Wow you know I love a woman like
one of the first things that I uh I
booked is a you know I booked this on my
think it was a Dairy Queen commercial
and i was i was playing basketball
instead of a basketballer using a live
chicken and it was awesome because um
you know I had them I had booked that
and I shot it and puppy like a week
later I get this call from this movie
called mallet chance and they're good
you know I got booked on the movie and
they're gonna fly me your new orleans at
that point i am this is this was back in
nineteen ninety nine you know cope no
two thousand at that point like I was
like I really felt like oh my god this
is like all happening you know and so um
it was just an amazing I guess I just
remember that feeling of course the the
movie never got done and you know it
everything like that and then all of a
sudden like after that I think it was
think it was over a year before I booked
anything but I guess I just remember
that feeling it's like you know you want
to do something you want to do something
you want to do something all sudden I
can do this it's like else and it was
like you can't do this it's like else
and it's in your head and that was
probably live in a way it may be like
the worst thing form because then I
really felt they could do this you know
I felt like um sometimes you feel like
you're not good enough for something but
I felt like I'm supposed to be doing
this you know I can definitely do this
so that was definitely a good feeling
when I got that call to to book that
movie to go to New Orleans
you